yvon deschamps bonjourbonjour centre sud
comment c'est fait la connexion cet
article vous connaissiez que vous êtes
de saint henri
absolument l'adie ressemblance oui la
seule différence je verrai ces passants
quartier ouvrier aussi à l'époque c'est
un dizaine on avait plus qu aux autres
parce que quand mon jeu d'enfant la zone
du canal la chaîne c'était la zone la
plus industrialisée au canada alors
c'était vraiment une même facture et
beauté du rdda côté de l'emploi on avait
des cours de triage par tous et toutes
des locomotives à vapeur
tout ça ça fonctionne au charbon alors
qu'on avait qui avait pas ici nous
autres on avait un nuage de suite où tu
m'aimes quand je faisais seule une fois
ma mamma roma folle et que des jours
qu'elle veut c'est un peu humaine elle
étendait son linge
cinq minutes après il y avait des
millions de grains noirs dessus tout la
suite de leur faudra car comment cela va
mal donc on était tranquille ça venait
avec un prix oui ou ethnique un peu
absolument
comment s'est fait le contact avec le
centre sur le centre se moque je sais je
suis gay et en force yoel peu notre
président un des fondateurs et puis à un
moment donné il ya 85 quand même à 35
ans il a acheté un petit bol des
missiles au levain besoin de rénover sa
cure en appeler s'offre une petite
campagne de 250 malveillance est ce que
vous pourriez à un porte parole du
président d'un art mais je suis
conseiller
alors je suis venu hélas il s'est même
raconter d'où il était parti aux autres
de rien son parti de rien et en fait les
bingos pour acheter une belle derniers
choisissent et incroyants alors elle y
parlait d' un jour voir le centre un
vrai qu'on va avoir un gymnase d'hommes
peuvent avoir une piscine
on va voir et la bibliothèque dans sa
tête à bibliothèque c'est tellement
important et tranquillement d'antan
c'est l'association sportive entressen
là c'est devenu après d'associations
sportives et communautaires
il a rajouté des programmes et des
programmes programme anti décrochage
antidrogue en ce moment il ya dix
programmes anti décrochage un des plus
beau c'est l'aide aux devoirs est ce que
ça vous émeut penser à ça de vous dire
que grâce à votre générosité par
générosité de d'autres est un quartier
qui a changé totalement change de monde
et que des milliers des milliers
d'enfants la sepsie h 7 jours pendant
assez pour des deux amis des décennies
et que c'est fabuleux
je n'étais juste à l'aide aux devoirs en
1 155 120 jeunes par jour qui viennent à
l'aide aux devoirs avant la cover
naturellement puis après ça va être à
vos revenus et la bibliothèque on a
parlé de judy - avait déjà un nombre on
trouve la côte est
il a gioda demande que ceux qui t'aiment
au centre vers des petits os x - j'aime
/ chill et la bibliothèque
extraordinaires qui l'ont fait parce que
ici il ya des programmes grand manteau
pour les emplois d'été des choses comme
ça ce qui fait que finalement tous de
l'administration il vous
ils vont chercher comme 20 25% de
d'argent public
mais le reste faut le trouver et c'est
ça coûte plus de 4 millions par année
juste faire marcher le sens laon pelouse
depuis quelques années folles elle
construit on partait tôt en phase ne
tout coûté 23
on en donne sanna persson c'est fabuleux
c'est fabuleux et vous ce qui est
fabuleux c'est que ça vous ça vous
apaise aussi d'avoir aidé comme ça un
projet comme ça ça faisait pas parti de
redonner ouais non mais c'est important
pour vous depuis début de redonner way
données de redonner d'être utile être
utile voilà le mot être touché ma main
radio c'était pas pour être utile de pas
besoin d'être là ok on va rentrer vont
déjà l'intérieur on va aller voir ce
magnifique scène dont une jambe ou
parler de la fondation de ce centre
l'extraordinaire ça m'amène à l'argent
et vous avez un rapport
vous avez eu un rapport compliqué avec
l'argent parce que c'est notre héritage
judéo-chrétien peut-être ouais on se
faisait dire que ces gens qui avaient de
leur chance que pas du bon moment où les
prix étaient méchants du bon donc sa
paume zotero alors j'avoue que quand je
me suis réveillé moment mais ça c'est
bon parce que je travaillais alors je
travaillais je pense ça passe et tout à
coup je rends compte que j'ai beaucoup
d'argent à la banque beaucoup beaucoup
et l'enjeu mais bruyant tôt que ce que
je fais avec ça je peux le faire à voir
son loft est mal et un moment donné je
suis sage ou digitick gpad affaire à moi
je dis donnait alors est attendu de vous
en tant que vous êtes mis à donner a
donné perdu un ouais trop vite je le dis
à jody parce que les tests le conseil
d'administration et ont tout donné
[Rires]
vous avez donné comme compulsivement
menée pour vous quand vous avez un
sentiment de culpabilité
voilà ça a commencé avec ça et après ben
là c'est plus j'irai de pouvoir aider
peut-être parce que tout ce qu'on
faisait
c'est qu'on commençait par une grosse
fondation la fondation privée est tout
petit mais on allait vers des choses que
personne d'autre elle est allée portes
que le gouvernement paye époque si on
faisait des affaires comme une sortie
pour chaise roulante
maintenant ça n'existait pas dans le
temps j'ai acheté beaucoup beaucoup de
transport des petits autobus pétrole
alors ce qui pouvait pas avoir ailleurs
l'oeil et nous le demande est là bon
c'est plus organisé votre fondation qui
contribue ici nous a énormément ça ça
doit vous faire plaisir quelque chose de
permanent là dedans c'est pas juste
donné qu'on sait pas trop à ça s'envole
c'est organisé ça fait plaisir et ça
change la vie de jeune ça change la vie
de milliers de jeunes chaque année c'est
fabuleux ce qui est ici ça existe ne pas
vers d'autres moi et on n'a qu'à
pandémie finissent pour que les jurés
aient fait pleinement bay 550 600 jeunes
par jour et ses locks promet aliot là on
est tranquille où malheureusement
comment vous l'avez vécu cette pandémie
le où est-ce que vous en avez profité
pour faire des choses que vous faisiez
pas comment est ce que ça a changé
quelque chose dans votre vie
depuis le mois de mars dernier ça a
changé beaucoup de choses à changer que
je vois pas mes enfants mes
petits-enfants aussi souvent que
j'aimerais c'est le plus que ça a changé
parce que comme je leur retraite alors
je travaillais déjà pas au programme
on va chez nous je reste chez nous notre
façon je lis je suis entre koch me moque
un peu de tout mais l'aude est isolé
j'appellerais sol
et de voir dans le pire de la crise des
personnes âgées mourir seul dans les
sièges celle du ca a été seul gros drame
c'est le drame des drames
quelles réflexions vous avez eue sur la
vieillesse puis sur comment on traite
nos vieux ou québec
je vais vous dire quelque chose à un
moment donné je commençais à entendre
les gens du grand maman qui dira à nos
vieux et c'est eux qui ont bâti le
québec bay
occupez vous à ça va être cinq ans
voulait laisser là moment mon père y est
mort on cherche à s'élever
mais dans les années 80 il y avait assez
henry service est excellent on y ait une
belle fin de vie mais depuis 20 ou 25
ans les recherches se dit et puis
demande et coach va vous dire un enfant
la jeune amy il faut voir sa mère se
sont alliés aux 7,8 à halle il va voir
sa main on lui dit ô et paulo il veut
contrôler ce que les on lui donne un ba1
hockey laisse promène dans corrida otaku
une porte ouverte si la grande salle de
bains sa mère est dans un harnais pendu
entière et a tenu à latin pour son bien
c'était l'heure du break
ils ont nous dit qu'il faut faire et
tant sur nos vies beh oui on aurait pu y
penser avant le feu 20 20 est un
concours concours concours le jugement
rappelle bigrement libéral e -u sur
pitau améliorer m'emmener n'ont pas mis
500 pour les vieux bon alors c'était
effrayant
moi j'allais voir mon père dans l'essai
chez celles des eaux des neiges est
régulièrement j'arrivais vers 11h le
matin du renmibi était dans sa couche
souliers depuis le matin parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas eu le temps d'y quelqu'un
qui a travaillé toute sa vie car ayez
ses impôts est ce que vraiment est-ce
que vous cruz avait espoir que ce choc
là qu'on a eu beau faire quand même
changer les choses
oui où il faut sinon on fait une
révolution je pense qu'on fait mais bon
ça mais c'est toujours difficilement mon
grand père naturellement ils
travaillaient pas trop gros on est bon
de s'en aller
et à 68 commencé à travailler à 12 ans
12 heures par jour 52 semaines par année
les ouvrir pour le doigt de vacances
avant 1938 et mon ventre antisèches pas
alors toute sa vie à 65 avions des
demandes ils ont retourné chez lui le et
en se couchant soit jamais grammes ainsi
que vaut payer le loyer à fin du mois on
n'a pas d'argent et que tu travailles 72
heures par semaine mais si t'as pas
assez pour mettre de l'argent de côté
alors il pleurait tout le temps un an
après ta mort à l'union quesada
désignons que celle-ci singer spiri ce
genre exactement alors la fin de vie
c'est toujours plein
[Musique]
datant du malade de gens s'attaquent
heures le pit est la clé pour dean à peu
près 12 heures et corse lorsque les
pompiers nous et si ta femme est tombée
malade sur jean cils noirs
quatre thèmes pas examen comme si
daniela contenues dans l'ouvragé
marester brest a dépensé quelque chose
je le dirai
bonnet
comment vous vivez votre vieillir c'est
absolument
comment vous la vivez comment la vivez
bien que mal en général
je ne vais pas bien chili général ça va
très bien mais si on se met à parler
maintenant ou une coupe devions entendre
par là j'ai mal ici à bella ça paraît
bien lol
le nombre de bobo qu'on a ça se peut pas
j'entends moins bien je vois moins bien
j'ai les jeunes homos le csv mais c'est
un petit peu comme quand on vend du
monde on est jeune maton 23,4 pas lyon 2
3 4 enfants sa coupe sacré saisit quand
ils font de ses passions pour commencer
demain commencé qu'un petit bébé puis
sont habitués de toi les beaux gosses
est passé d'un bobo à deux bobos trop
beau donc vous voulez bien le fait de
vieillir
oui absolument
savez-vous - pourquoi vous êtes en
faveur des monts ma libération de la
femme ne savent à quel saint rapport
même moment beauté pourquoi pas ce que
c'est c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas
des vraies femmes c'est parce que vous
n'êtes pas capable d'assumer votre rôle
de femme c'est à dire de subalterne
four monologue que j'ai beaucoup écouté
des juges quand j'étais 15 16 17 ans
j'ai eu beaucoup et beauté vie
libération de la femme à coups en fait
tout était de 69 à bourg monologue
jusqu'à 75
ouais est ce que vous pourriez faire ça
aujourd'hui vos cours beaucoup il y en a
beaucoup
naturellement mais en aucun cas celui
qui dénonçait le racisme qu'on n'ose
quasiment pas de leur mieux mais on peut
plus non avec un vous qu'on peut choisir
vous pourriez plus pourtant sainte
secude il faudrait changer
ouais il faudrait changer des mots pour
pour deux pour qu'il soit ce qui devait
être parce qu'en fait c'est un monologue
qui était qt amant seul mais plus jolie
m'attend mais y avait soit c'était pour
elle madame l'intérêt comme celle au
deuxième étage à vingt six appartements
je suis par les treks turcot et puis il
d'un jeu suit enfin
et puis ma même chose où j'arrive là et
y avait de mémé et mono y avait un père
une mère et frère issa tout pareil comme
chez nous sa mère faisait des crêpes
comme ça sur un bonhomme qui ont fait un
travail aussi bien son grand frère
jouait d'un arc s de nec
l'épisode ya l'école jamais d'un
pédalier à l'école mais je vous parle
beau monologue parce que moi ça m'a
marqué sa marque et
ça a marqué tout le monde qui les a
rendus comment vous portez le que vous
êtes le père de l'humour au québec comme
et vous comment vous portez en vous je
vois toutes les photos derrière vous
dire je vous demande ça mais comment
vous portez ce statut de demi-dieu
d'humour au jeune savoyard
oui oui non non je me sauve beaucoup
beaucoup j'aime ça et quoi de mieux de
faire dit att bon que tu est un has been
peut cacher sa fière de ce refus
je suis fier je veux j'ai travaillé fort
et ça comme beaucoup de monde mais ça a
donné que moi ça a marché jusqu'à l'aube
bon moment j'ai les a failli qu'il
fallait dire à ce moment là puis alors
rech pierre est fier heureux parce que
j'ai pas fait exprès mais heureux que ce
soit parce que j'ai eu une belle
carrière puisque j'ai encore je me dis
je partir en tournée demain je remplirai
message ce jeu sûrs de ce alors c'est
une fan en cause
est ce que ça vous remet un nom sa maman
non mais ça vous manquait ça m'a pris
deux trois ans alors prendre sa retraite
c'est pas simple il faut vouloir en
moselle il faut travailler ça pris 2 3 1
régulièrement je me levais j'ai une
bonne idée je vous écris un monologue la
turbie et m'emmener non non et non et
tout à coup un jour à je le savais que
j'étais correct que j'étais ya je
reviendrai plus grave parce que j'avais
plus ses envies leurs d'alors j'avais
toujours dit écrire c'est ce qui est bon
ou pas un matin la pandémie ou telle
décision politique qui vous inspire un
monologue est plus la dalle non medellin
des forges et enjeux des lignes des fois
jme j'ai déjà tout dit
les bonnes mains vous en êtes dans la
ronde échanges sur la question nationale
sur le québec
etes-vous toujours souveraine et c'est
ce que vous êtes où vous en êtes dans
votre rapport à cette question là ouais
ce que ça existe encore pauvre existe
toujours
je suis toujours séparatistes dans ce
sens que quand on a fait tant que le
canada acceptent europe en conçoit
québec français protégé par la
constitution canadien joue et qui sait
pas si le parti québécois fait une très
grave erreur de faim le référendum ça
dit de faire la loi 100 avant le
référent pourquoi on serait séparé pour
hugues pour notre culture pour notre
langue ça c'est important
mais là ils disent c'est correct ce site
pas de problème pour la langue la
culture
voulez vous vous séparez non mais c'est
pas un débat qui vient vous chercher
encore parce que je parle de simple il
ya un nouveau le dixième chef du bloc
québécois
je mets donc comment il le regard des
sacs à main
il se positionne face à ce homme j'avoue
que je devrais pas dire ça mais je suis
parti québécois voir la misère pour moi
à survivre alors il ya des instants pour
chaque chose et que je pense que le
temps du parti même parti a fait son
temps peut-être que notre jeune nouveau
chef votre tout animé sa pile en cinq
ans on va devoir ouvrage ils ont des
champs donc à spectacle-bénéfice oui
parce qu'il faut continuer à financer se
sentent absolument
et aussi parce que j'ai 85 vous allez
faire quoi sur la scène vendredi vous
allez jouer à nu mais vous allez faire
mal à nouveau des noms un que j'ai re
travailler sur la mémoire parce que j'ai
plein d'amis qui ont l'alzheimer et
l'autre leur travail c'est mes
grands-mères jeu se pose en vrai tout
haut mais note savvas ku
doivent être vaincus et puis je vais
animer mais c'est très important je vais
vous dire c'est que le fait d'avoir 85
ans a à lui même qu à chaque visite est
plus là pour longtemps
alors je veux que ça continue quand je
serai plus là c'est pour cela le grand
événement 85 ans je mange tout le monde
qui m'ont aimée tout le monde que fait
quelques choix ou tout le monde qui me
trop faim partout bain
venez vous venez fêter avec moi mais 85
ans plus tard jean lavallée pour être
sûr que même si quand je vois est mort
ça continue entre qu'on vous aime
beaucoup ils vont payer mais voilà ça va
marcher
merci beaucoup
aimons nous quand même aimons nous jour
après jour aimons nous quand même
m
nous malgré l'amour